In the year 2030, 58% of adults will be overweight according to statistics.
Thanks to lifts, escalators, cars, chairs, computers,...
...we will be more and more sedentary.
By the year 2030, 60% of the world's population will live in cities...
...and we'll spend most of our time sitting or lying down.
In spite of all this, we will still feel stressed and 20% will have trouble sleeping.
By that year, 60% of all children are likely not to have seen a cow...
...and bad dietary habits will continue to increase.
This is what our world will be like in the year 2030 according to statistics.
But the only real statistic is that 100% of statistics are made by us...
...and we are going to change them.
What if we stand up?